[Música]
muy buenos días bienvenidos estas son
las noticias más destacadas hasta esta
hora aquí en france 24 comenzamos esta
actualización en perú este país celebra
hoy y diario día ya dio inicio a la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales en las que se enfrenta a
keiko fujimori del partido fuerza
popular que representa la extrema
derecha y pedro castillo de perú libre
que representa la izquierda ambas
propuestas son completamente opuestas y
el debate está concentrado en mantener a
perú en un modelo neoliberal que es el
mismo que ha permanecido en los últimos
30 años o en dar un giro radical hacia
la izquierda 25 millones de votantes
están convocados a las urnas después de
unas campañas en las que hubo lluvia de
propuestas pero con muy pocos planes de
acción y poco planes claros en medio de
polémicas también se desarrollaron estas
campañas crisis sanitaria inestabilidad
política y un empate técnico entre los
candidatos quien asuma el poder el
próximo 28 de julio será el presidente
para los próximos cinco años en el
bicentenario de la independencia de perú
la jornada electoral se extenderá por
espacios
12 horas previamente conversamos con
francisco zacarías el corresponsal de
france 24 en perú y nos dio más detalles
del inicio de esta jornada electoral
todavía no se ve muchos electores es que
en realidad el clima que se vive en perú
es de un país polarizado más de 25
millones de ciudadanos van a salir a
sufragar en esta segunda vuelta que está
salpicado por rumores psicosociales y
campañas de ataque entre uno y otro
partido político a esto se ha sumado
también enfrentamientos diversos
analistas ha dicho que esta polarización
va a llevar al final de resultados a que
el candidato o los simpatizantes de la
propuesta que pierda va a ser reclamos y
esto podría extenderse en los siguientes
días a que se den a conocer los
resultados oficiales por la oficina
nacional de procesos electorales del
perú y méxico- también vivirá el día de
hoy una jornada electoral de hecho es la
jornada electoral más grande de la
historia democrática de ese país 95
millones de ciudadanos están llamados a
las urnas
para elegir 15 gobernaciones también la
renovación de los 500 integrantes de la
cámara de diputados- y más de 21 mil
cargos públicos es también el primer
proceso electoral a nivel federal en
medio de la pandemia de kobe 19 sin
embargo las campañas electorales han
estado marcadas por la violencia
política como la intimidación y también
el asesinato de cerca de 89 políticos 35
de ellos eran aspirantes a un cargo de
elección popular estos comicios también
servirán para asentar o no el peso del
partido oficialista morena que según los
sondeos tiene ventaja en la preferencia
de voto por encima de los partidos
tradicionales como el pri y el pan
y nos vamos hasta nicaragua el político
de la oposición artur o cruz se
convirtió en el segundo candidato a la
presidencia de ese país centroamericano
en ser detenido por las autoridades a lo
largo de esta semana cruzo fue arrestado
el sábado por los agentes de la policía
nacional en el aeropuerto internacional
de managua tan pronto desembarco en un
vuelo procedente de eeuu el académico es
investigado por presuntamente atentar
contra la sociedad nicaragüense y los
derechos del pueblo según lo dijo el
ministerio público a esto se suma
también la detención de la también
aspirante a la presidencia de nicaragua
cristiana chamorro barrios quien
permanece en arresto domiciliario otro
candidato félix maradiaga fue citado
también por las autoridades para dar su
versión sobre unas presuntas acusaciones
por parte del gobierno estos hechos
tienen lugar solamente cinco meses antes
de los comicios en los que el mandatario
daniel ortega buscará reelegirse por
tercera vez consecutiva junto a su
esposa actual vicepresidenta de
nicaragua rosario murillo
exigimos liberar al candidato arturo
cruz es inaceptable la manipulación de
las fuerzas de seguridad y de la
justicia para encarcelar a candidatos
opositores lo cual pone a nicaragua
fuera de la legalidad interamericana e
internacional estas acciones son
contrarias a las elecciones libres y
justas es todo por el momento recuerde
que cada 30 minutos tenemos una
actualización de noticias aquí en france
24 siga con nosotros buen día
[Música]